jean-luc python en garde à vue l'envers
d'une carrière entièrement tissé autour
du linge de maison des draps des
peignoirs destinés aux plus grandes
marques de l'hôtellerie un entrepreneur
réputé qui fut aussi président du medef
en franche comté
jean-luc python a été placé en garde à
vue hier
il est suspecté d'abus de biens sociaux
et de banqueroute en clair il aurait
détourné près de 300000 euros ces
dernières années de ces deux sociétés de
luxeuil-les-bains des sommes directement
versé sur des comptes bancaires à
l'étranger dans le cadre de l' enquête
nous avons demandé au juge des libertés
la détention provisoire parce que nous
craignons la disparition de preuves ou
craignant un entraînement également que
monsieur python prennent la fuite à
l'étranger puisque nous savons qu'ils
disposent de comptes à oman mais
également aux états unis au printemps
dernier le repreneur d'une des sociétés
appartenant à jean luc python s'était
étonné l'entreprise avait été vendu sans
le fichier clients et les modèles de
broderie une plainte avait été déposée
la peine encourue pour l'abus de bien
social et de cinq ans d'emprisonnement